get ready to learn from one of the most
influential medical personalities on the
internet wait I was supposed to say that
so stupid
Dr Mike is a board-certified family
physician and social media personality
Who Rose to Fame after being named the
sexiest doctor alive in 2015. with a
passion for promoting health and
wellness he's used his platform to
educate and Inspire millions of people
around the world and today you'll get to
hear his thoughts along with some really
dangerous medical advice that you'll
need to watch out for when they would
look at certain supplements like protein
powders and find like heavy metal
toxicity in them because they're not
carefully monitored did you check out
your lumps
how about this you're gonna have to
subscribe to find out if he checks out
Graham's lumps just subscribe thank you
guys so much and now let's begin but you
know what before we go into that we
gotta thank our sponsor Creative Juice
imagine this you're a content creator
that's been pouring your heart and soul
into your business you're starting to
pull views and that sweet sweet ad
revenue is just beginning to roll in but
as you're managing your finances it
becomes very confusing to determine
which of those are personal and which
are for the business well this is where
Creative Juice comes in they offer a
business banking account made
specifically for creators like us not
only do they offer a debit card with
rewards invoicing team collaboration
tools and real-time analytics but they
also provide funding through their juice
funds program with juice funds you can
get the financing you need to create the
content you want while maintaining a
hundred percent control choose between
the refresh program for short-term needs
or Reserve up to two million dollars in
funding to grow your business they have
flexible deal length starting at just
three months trust-based relationships
easy payouts and dedicated support from
industry experts you could use funds to
purchase Studio space hire freelance
help or cover other inevitable expenses
that come with being a Creator like you
see the studio guys I can tell you
firsthand we did our best to save money
but it was not very cheap everything you
see behind the scenes here costs a lot
and yes I am talking about you Alex
so take control of your creator business
today and sign up for a free Creative
Juice business banking account with the
link Down Below in the description or
you could also go to getjuice.com get
funding to get started today and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast don't let me know I'm getting
back to it we're getting to the podcast
did you see Mr BEAST's last video I did
I did epic video what do you think about
it I think it's going to start a new
like entire genre on YouTube for him
venturing into health is really exciting
because what I think he has the ability
to do is bring awareness
from the average person's mindset of
what's wrong with our Health Care system
and if you change enough minds and you
educate enough Minds you can actually
get the government to fix some of the
huge problems we have what exactly was
wrong with the eye my understanding was
that there was like a like a a liquid or
something that could be sucked out yeah
so basically what it is is uh it's
cataract uh induced Vision blurriness
which can be so bad that it can lead to
blindness essentially and uh cataracts
is like a haziness of the lens of the
eye which you could actually take the
lens out and put an artificial lens in
and it's a quick procedure like you you
saw in his video at six minutes six
minutes yep does it fix it forever
um I should clarify it's six to ten
minutes depending on okay but whatever
it's very quick it's a minutes procedure
right
um and it's very fast it's expensive as
well I have no idea about the cost
because it's not a procedure I do I
wouldn't even know how to price it I was
actually curious that myself when he was
doing it I was shocked it was only he's
I think he said 10 minutes yeah is that
something that people have to be put
under for or like how do you operate on
the eye it's a mild sedation the lowest
amount of sedation you can get the
reason why I say that is because as a
primary care doctor I do
pre-operative clearances to make sure
that people are safe going in for
surgery and a lot of times eye doctors
will send me their patients before they
go for surgery a lot of times it's
someone older and like there's not much
you do for that surgery because it's
such a low risk procedure it's so quick
it's outpatient they're not under
anesthesia for hours at a time it's
minutes so the the risk of anything
going wrong is very low so there's very
little that I can do to prepare them to
be in the best scenario but what do they
see when this surgery is going uh like
underway how does that work that
someone's like able to look at their eye
and they don't move their eye
um well my assumption is that they're
sedated but it's again it's not a
procedure that I would do it's an
Ophthalmology procedure so what exactly
what type of procedures do did you do or
do you do so being primary care I work
in an outpatient Medical Center
obviously I'm trained to perform surgery
like my medical license in New York and
New Jersey is both for medical and
Surgical but unless you're in a bind you
don't want me performing your surgery
because I didn't do my residency in
surgery meaning that I didn't get the
extra Hands-On hours in the operating
room
um so the the minor surgeries that I do
are skin procedures biopsies inds which
are like incision and drainage of an
abscess the ingrown toenail removal very
superficial things like I'm not going to
be doing an appendectomy or uh I don't
know some kind of colon procedure sure
so it's more outpatient based stuff that
your primary doctor how did you get
started did you always know you wanted
to be a doctor you know for me I fell in
love with medicine because my father was
a doctor in Russia and when we came to
the states he had to redo medical school
and residency and I was 10 years old so
I was awake if you will during that time
into seeing what he's doing most kids
are so young when their parents are in
medical school that they don't know what
the whole process is like but for me I
witnessed it from day one his first day
of going into medical school till his
residency days to becoming a doctor to
starting his own practice and I fell in
love with it I said this is what I want
to do it fit my skill set real well I
loved science it was like the only
subject I really would pay attention to
in class and I said that's that's the
field for me do you ever get queasy when
you see blood or there's one thing that
makes me queasy and what is it watching
someone gag really did you start gagging
too yes that's a thing I know people
that like feel like they need to like
vomit or whatever someone else does why
why no why is that a thing no idea I've
been in a room where there's massive
blood loss I've plugged massive blood
loss uh there's excrement in rooms that
I've been in and there's no issue for me
but then like if I'm putting on a
nasogastric tube for a patient which is
a tube that's supposed to go from your
nose and then you insert it and it goes
into the stomach whether you're trying
to like wash the area out if there's a
bleed or if there's an obstruction and
you're trying to pull content out of the
stomach but you're putting this tube in
sometimes the tube will coil in the
mouth triggering the gag reflex and when
I'm doing that for a patient if it
triggers that gag reflex in them for me
I almost like start gagging and throwing
have you ever gagged and like yes it was
really bad the patient was like oh whoa
what like the patient was not fully
there like they were a little bit out of
it based on their medical conditions so
they didn't realize it but the
co-resident I was working with my senior
resident saw me and was like are you
okay I'm like no I'm good and I was able
to fight through it but I feel it like I
don't it's not controllable I get so
queasy and so just like
lightheaded if I see blood or me too me
too your own blood or anyone's anyone's
interesting anything uh anything where
like if some were on an operating room I
wouldn't I would have an out-of-body
experience I couldn't comprehend what's
going on okay yeah like I think that's a
person right there on that table like
their life is in these other person's
hands and anything goes wrong like
that's that's her whole life is led up
to that point I just can't conceptualize
that yeah it is scary being in that
moment the thing is when you're uh a
practicing physician you have so many
hours and times that you were in there
and remember the first times you're in
there you're in there as a medical
student just observing so you have no
real job so you kind of go in there just
observe it then you're going in and
maybe you're assisting holding a tool or
holding the surgical Field open then
you're going in and now you're a
resident and you're actually assisting
in doing the procedure then you're being
the senior doctor overseeing the
procedure the the Mantra that we have is
C1 do one teach one and that's kind of
how surgery is learned so by the time
you're actually responsible for that
person's life you've done this so many
times that usually the nerves are gone
at that point got it I'm with you on the
blood loss today is that for me freaks
me out so I took Accutane when I was in
high school and you need to get your
blood drawn I think it's like once every
month or so to monitor all of your
levels and everything and I was on it
for five months and I went in once
because I was so scared I was just like
oh you know I can't come in like
something came when you get your blood
drawn yeah you had to get your blood
drawn and you were worried about it and
I was worried and I literally skipped
out to the point where they're like hey
we gotta like we can't keep you on
Accutane sure if you're just gonna keep
skipping out in your blood appointments
and I was like ah like I was like I
don't know do you still have that
problem now yes I was actually going to
get my blood drawn before this New York
trip and I was gonna go with my
housemate then they decided to go with
their girlfriend so I decided not to go
but I need to get my blood drawn really
bad I just went and had my blood drawn
like two weeks ago I wish we could have
gone together how was that for you uh
easy and I get so weirded out by it like
what if you don't look
uh I start sweating yeah it's the idea
of it it's not like whether or not like
the pain is no pain yeah it feels like a
little pinch but it's the idea of what's
going on I think about it yeah I just
don't know why they need to take so much
it's like don't you think that it's
actually not much at all yeah but like
like you're thinking
there's no pint no one's taking a pint
for I can't change
that's donating blood okay okay well if
they're still taking like what do they
call vile right yeah I feel like inside
of vials like five MLS which is like a
teaspoon oh it's not that bad actually
okay so I thought it was like I thought
it was like a full-on tube or a
tablespoon but yeah it's not much all
right that's that's not too bad I still
feel like they could only just like give
you a little prick on your finger and
then just like you know extract it well
that's if you're doing like a blood
sugar checking okay but otherwise you
need a little bit more blood I'm
actually on the same team as Dr Mike I
only get I only gag when other people
gag and uh I wanted to be I I wanted to
do like EMT when I was in high school I
actually watched an open heart surgery
whoa yeah those that's scary that's
crazy yeah what do you mean you watched
an Open Hearts like in person yeah we
went to go look are you serious yeah
yeah there's like operating Bays with
they call them theaters yeah we're like
on the top that you could sit and watch
or maybe on the side and you're
protected and it's still anyone watches
no it's generally reserved for students
or like educational purposes yeah and
what about the person is that something
that they consent to yeah okay so it's
not just like you're just like
surprisingly wheeled into a room yeah
also remember if you're getting a
surgery in like a university hospital
odds are is a teaching hospital and in a
teaching Hospital you're gonna have
other people in the room interesting
okay do you find it safer to go to a
teaching hospital because there's so
many people on it I think it depends
what you're going for okay if you have a
very complex issue yes because odds are
are they're going to be the ones doing
research on this very complex issue and
then also a lot of the research
hospitals are the ones that are like
level one Trauma Centers so if something
really bad happens you end up in those
places that's interesting I represented
a client who is a I think he went to USC
but he got very good at treating
gunshots and that was one of the things
where
for people to learn of how to treat like
instant wounds and stuff like that that
was one of the best places and he
interesting yeah went into medicine yeah
like one of my friends he's an ER doctor
he recently finished his residency
training he did an extra stint in
Baltimore where there's unfortunately a
lot of shootings and gang violence so he
would come back with stories of knowing
how to treat stabbings accidents
shootings gunshot wounds and it's
unfortunate but it's also given him a
lot of education and value to bring back
to his patients here and you see in
those worse areas how much education
happens and how terrible it is but first
we got to thank today's sponsor stream
yard of which doing it on my own today
because Jack is not here I have no idea
where he is I've tried texting him
multiple times hasn't got back to me so
uh here we are oh my gosh guys I'm late
to film The Stream yard sponsor again
I'm gonna be in so much trouble I really
hope Graham doesn't start without me uh
stay tuned to the end of the sponsor to
see if I can make it on time anyway if
Jack was here I would tell him that
stream yard is a live streaming Studio
platform that's perfect for people
looking to get into content creation and
make high quality content even better
with stream yard all you need to get
started is an internet connection and a
camera you don't even need to be on time
from there you could live stream your
content directly from your browser to
multiple social media platforms
including Facebook YouTube LinkedIn and
more
best of all you could stream to all of
them at the same time simply put you
could increase your Outreach for free
stream yard also offers tons of
different analytic tools that can help
you measure the success of each one of
your live streams and knowing which
social media platform is drawing the
most of your viewers can help you really
optimize for that so if you want to
start creating content streamer is the
best place to get started without
spending any money
[Music]
so check out stream yard today using the
link Down Below in the description I
made guys I made it on time I'm so sorry
Graham I'm late check out stream yard
today using the link Down Below in the
description it's completely free thank
you so much stream yard thank you Graham
for being patient guys if you want us to
do some sort of skit or almost anything
in the next streamer at ad read they
gave us full permission to do whatever
we want so whatever you say Down Below
in the description we'll pick a few and
we'll just go ahead and do it so uh with
that said thank you so much thanks to
stream yard for being accommodating on
this and now let's get back to the
podcast by the way guys before we go
into that I just want to throw this in I
know it's very abrupt but we did
something we bought the domain iced
coffee hour dot Club it might be asking
Graham why is it a DOT Club well because
I'll tell you because.com was taken so
if you guys want to see how to get merch
just like this very very cool merch you
want to look as cool as me check it out
with the link Down Below in the
description we also have subscription
tiers where you can access neat things
such as videos without ads your name
shown at the end of the video and also
extra episodes each month where it's
just us and you can only see that on our
website we have a VIP tier where we
really only have a few people in there
but we get to hang out the last time we
did this we all got to hang out we got a
private bowling Suite here in Las Vegas
we spent all the money that we make on
that back on the event itself so just a
fantastic time check it out with the
link Down Below in the description and
we're running a limited time sale that's
going on right now so if you're the
first to sign up you will get a discount
so enjoy that discount for the first
month enjoy and now with that said let's
get back to the episode how did you
decide what segment to go into what type
of medicine when I was in medical school
I actually thought I was going to do
surgery and I thought that was the field
for me especially I was like Loving
video games you see my PS5 here and I
was like that's what surgery is going to
become there's robot surgery now and in
reality I started going in and scrubbing
into those surgeries I did like 60 of
them in my third year of medical school
I realized this isn't for me it's not
human enough in terms of interaction
with the human because your patient's
asleep most of the time
um you don't have good continuity
meaning like once you fix the issue you
don't see that person anymore and I saw
the value in Family Medicine where if
someone comes in with an issue a I'm
playing detective I'm trying to figure
out what they need but then at the same
time is Once I make it into intervention
and fix the problem I still keep seeing
them and get to live life with this
person I get to see the benefits of
treating them I get to see that they
were able to start a family like I
remember uh one of my first two patients
on my schedule were husband and wife
that were there for similar reasons he
was here he was there for sexual
dysfunction and she was there for a
problem with conception getting pregnant
and obviously I knew what the issue was
because the husband is having this
problem and I found it was because of a
medicine he was on for his prostate size
I switched the medicine he was able to
get an erection they were able to
conceive I delivered the baby the baby
was my patient and that's only going to
happen if your primary care because
you're able to follow the whole journey
of the family why is surgery so far
removed in terms of not following up
with patient is that done for a reason
that you could say like objective or or
be less emotional about this the
surgeon's it's a transactional field a
person percent has problem a you do
treatment B they get better that's it
there's no need to see the surgeon after
like if you have an appendicitis and you
need your your appendix removed once the
surgeon takes out your appendix maybe
does one follow-up you don't continue
seeing the surgeon like what would you
even see them for so it's the nature of
the field being so transactional and and
problem solving which is good because a
lot of people are like that they want to
solve the problem move on but then you
kind of lose the growth of that person
and throughout their livelihood why are
some of these surgeries so expensive
because you see in the U.S it's like
quarter million dollars for a surgery
but then you'll see it done overseas for
30 grand 40. yeah overseas it's
difficult to compare because now you're
comparing Health Systems which some are
government funded meaning taxpayer
funded uh in other areas there's hybrid
systems like what we have here in the
States but the the number one reason
that I see it happening here is because
we don't have transparency in pricing so
if you for example want to have a
cosmetic surgery in America you can call
10 cosmetics practices and say Hey I
want to get a nose job what's the cost
of a nose job and they will tell you
their price because they don't have to
negotiate with an insurance company they
they you have to pay them so you can get
fair pricing and you could choose the
one that you think is the best value
well good luck calling hospitals and
saying hey I need a an appendectomy
because I have an appendicitis which one
is going to give me the best rates they
won't be able to give you that because
they have different prices for one
insurance they have an agreement with
this other insurance and it's a disaster
why is it so inefficient how have they
not figured out a better way to to do
that why is it why do they have to
charge different insurance companies
different rates because it's hybridized
so far it's almost like a mutated system
it started off in one way then someone
had another idea to bring one approach
then someone had another approach and
now it's so segmented that and and this
is largely driven by lobbyists who come
in and start lobbying the government to
say oh we need multiple insurance
carriers we need these rules for
insurance carriers and as a result for
me if you walk into my practice and I
tell you you need treatment a I can't
even tell you what the cost of treatment
day is because it's so dependent on
variables that are outside of my control
because it depends is your like for
example if a patient comes in and they
tell me they fell and I write that in
the chart patient fell blah blah blah in
the note I say oh they fell at work they
were doing X Y and Z and I finished the
note I send it to their insurance
carrier their insurance their health
insurance might deny that claim and say
what do you mean they fell at work you
said in your note that means they uh
their health workers compensation has to
cover not us or the same thing will
happen with a car accident a patient
will come to see me and they'll say my
back hurts but in the note they'll say
oh I had a car accident four years ago
the insurance will deny it and say the
auto insurance is supposed to pay for
this so they all like kick the bucket on
who's supposed to make the payment so
it's a complete disaster in terms of
care like you cannot imagine a more
broken system and the fact that it still
somehow Works to some degree is magical
so that's what partially happened to me
when I did a skin checkup
um I had a mole that I went online for
and WebMD said it was uh basal cell so I
got it I wanted to get it checked out
but the wait was two months to get in
or I just pay 250 out of pocket I go to
the person down the street and that's
what I did and I got in the next morning
why is that such a difficult process to
like two months to get an appointment oh
that was to get to the appointment just
to get the recommendation so I had to
see the primary to get this the the
specialty doctor after so it would be
like three months yeah a lot of times
this is created by our capitalistic
system where
doctors that are in demand realize that
working with insurance companies will
yield a lower profit than working with
individuals who have cash who want
on-demand service
so they leave the insurance game and
they say I'm only going to accept cash
payments from now on and that way they
know exactly what they're getting paid
they don't have to argue with insurers
and as a result they are more
financially successful than doctors who
accept insurance and that's largely a
generalization but usually if you're
accepting cash you're doing better than
most I've heard somewhere I don't know
if this is true at all I I know nothing
about the Health Care System but are
doctors contractors for the hospital in
some situations or are they like the
calorie employees it's both so what is
the contract situation look like do they
like rent the the space that they have
so sometimes there's so many different
Arrangements that can happen but I'll
give you like for example in ERS it's
very common that a hospital system would
contract an ER employer who then has a
bunch of ER doctors that work for them
and then they'll just place them at
certain shifts at different hospitals
so they don't even work for the hospital
they work for the ER employer who then
puts them in different Staffing sort of
locations and then you have private
practices like my dad currently is a
primary care doctor and he has a private
practice those are getting bought up by
Hospital systems and they'll pay the
provider a small amount of money or a
large amount of money depending on how
successful the practice is and then say
okay we essentially own all of your
patients there are members of our
practice so that if you refer patients
it should be within our system
etc etc and now all of these smaller
doctors that used to run their own sort
of shops if you will are now part of a
great health system like a bigger health
system so there's less and less
individualized practices so what do you
think is one of the biggest issues that
or what one of the things that creates
these issues is it is it the amount of
doctors that we have is it the fact that
they incur so much debt going through
college that it kind of deters people
a bunch of money in order to pay it off
that's most definitely an issue med
school is crazy expensive to the tune of
if you're talking med school and college
it's six hundred thousand dollars of
loans not living expenses excluded
that's just for the education component
then obviously uh the idea of why
doctors are selling their practices is
because of administrative burden the
idea that there's like 10 different
insurance companies that have 10
different rules so when a patient comes
into my practice I'll you know fill out
a note and then I have to build that
note to the insurance company but let's
say I write a code for their condition
that let's say doesn't fit the test
requirement that they have to pay for
that blood test the bill will go to the
patient the patient say what the heck
why is this not being covered and it's
because insurer didn't like the code
that I put so this creates this huge
administrative burden on doctors where
we're like screw this we don't want to
practice this way we want the hospital
systems to take care of it but then when
Hospital Systems take care of it it
doesn't it loses that Personal Touch
that you have with your doctor because
now essentially you're a contractor
being contracted to see a patient every
15 minutes as opposed to create an
informed how difficult is it to collect
payments because you mentioned One
Insurance Company kicking it to another
and I bet the car place is like no it's
them and then
the cost of Health Care in America has
ballooned over the last 20 30 years and
it's not because doctors cost more to
the system in fact doctors like cost of
the system has stayed pretty stable or
has gone up slightly with the cost of
inflation but the idea of Health Care
has skyrocketed because for every doctor
you need like 10 to 15 administrators
you need a person to argue with
insurance company you need a person to
make sure the billing is right from the
doctor's side you need someone doing
prior authorizations to argue for your
patients to get certain tests done it's
it's literally a disaster is there a
solution to this I mean it's no there's
no well some people will say Universal
Health Care is the solution I think it
could be a potential solution but
there's no one-size-fits-all answer
because some people will say well
Universal Health Care isn't free
healthcare it's still paid by somebody
it's paid by us that's taxpayers so some
people will argue against that and if
we're being honest whatever the
government does usually isn't the most
effective or efficient way of doing
things so you could easily see more
troubles arises yeah in that scenario as
well if you were in control of the
system no I do what you you would have
no idea
is
I remember my parents and a lot of
people we never had to worry about
certain things because I remember we had
a co-pay right long or gone are like the
ages of the majority of people having
co-pays and now when I do insurance we
have deductibles why has Insurance
switched from this model of you know
having people pay a predictable price
when they go to the doctor to basically
now I have insurance in case I get into
a crazy accident in my bills I can't
afford sure
um that's a great question and it's a
very simple answer Insurance costs have
gone up but they wanted to make it seem
like they didn't
so the insurers are really good at
hiding the costs from you of what your
care actually costs so what they do is
let's say 10 years ago you would pay a
thousand dollars a month for your health
insurance but at that time you had some
co-pays which were small and no real
deductibles now you'll still pay a
thousand dollars a month for your
insurance but now the first five
thousand dollars you have to pay which
is your deductible right so the cost is
tremendously higher but when you're
making your monthly payments you don't
even realize that it's higher so
insurers instead of making less money
because they're not efficient at
handling our health care System they
just push the cost burden back onto the
the consumer is there a country that
you've seen that's done the Health Care
system in a way that you like or that's
maybe efficient or is it just I'm not an
expert
um you know I have friends that work in
the Canadian Health Care system and they
brought up issues that they have with
their own system I've heard people in
the UK Canada is a long time like six
I've heard weights are a long time but
then they don't have to worry about
going to the emergency room right
because of fees or the ambulance costs
being out of control so there's pros and
cons and some people might like one
system better than the other I think
there's a lot of intricacies that you
would miss out on unless you practice in
those or you're an expert in those
countries I kind of wish there were a
flat tax like an extra one percent tax
it's a one percent health care tax
across the board everyone pays one
percent wow
but Healthcare is free is it bad I don't
know I don't know I wish somebody would
have thought about that earlier it's
easy it's one percent like that math
like adds up you know I gotta think
about it I mean probably not I I don't
know I have a great Finance related
Medicare is 2.4 right or something like
that I don't like that people don't want
their time good luck asking people to
raise their taxes and winning on that
let me let me run by this quick tick
tock life hack that I ran across okay I
love this meme reacting doctor so I've
heard people online because you were
talking about how hard it is to collect
I I heard people online saying oh if you
have medical debt then like write them a
letter because HIPAA doesn't allow
doctors to disclose what medical
information or whatever and then
basically it's it's when the debt goes
to to like a debt collection company
are how how are people collected is that
true you mean like how do they collect
debt um yeah so basically
there's multiple ways they do go to debt
collection agencies some Hospital
Systems have gotten in trouble for suing
families in court over unpaid fees
that's been like an issue in the news
um and the the one piece of maybe you
could call this a tick tock life hack
advice is if you feel like your fee is
high or unfair or you don't have the
funds to pay it
always argue every bill every Bill the
reason why is a lot of times it's an
error on coding like I didn't write the
code that would get your test covered as
a doctor because I have no idea so
someone in administration can change the
code and get it covered that's number
one number two when Health insurers
charge you a fee let's say you're paying
out of pocket for a condition like you
have no insurance and you go to the
emergency room and the hospital charges
100 I'm making this up a hundred dollars
for an emergency appendix removal they
have to charge you as a cash user the
same amount by law in order to charge it
to the health insurance company but they
know the health insurance company why
they're charging them a hundred because
they'll only pay them 60. that's the
deal that they have with the health
insurance so when you get the bill for a
hundred and you argue they'll right away
lower it to 60.
they just can't do that by law but they
can do it if you're claim financial
hardship
wow I think you just saved a lot of
people in Needles I mean I say that
quite often like always argue your bills
because a lot of them are mistakes and
if they're not mistakes there's
financial support programs like
my hospital system that I work for is a
non-profit and we have a charity care
system in place for those who fall below
the poverty line or near the poverty
line and like I see patients all day
long that are either
seeing me completely for free are
getting scans done completely for free
getting surgeries for free getting
scheduled with Specialists for free so
like there are systems in place it just
a lot of people aren't aware of those
systems so they go underutilized when
did you start doing YouTube videos what
prompted that because it seems like two
totally different yeah it's a different
world and you don't see at least five
years ago you didn't see doctors on
social media when I was uh a resident I
had a viral moment of Fame for
superficial reasons it was like BuzzFeed
wrote an article like check out this
doctor in his Husky and it was nothing
about my medical accomplishments not
that I was the youngest doctor in my
hospital and they did research it was
like 2015. okay and in that moment I had
to be like okay do I like accept this do
I go on the TV shows and play the hot
doctor thing or that was what it was
that was yeah I was like check out this
hot doctor and his husband no that was
the name of the article yeah
where a lot of people were going viral
for their looks like there was a the
target the convict this year oh the
convict yeah yeah wow the weather person
like there was a lot of people going
viral I was
2015. it was 25 25. how did they find
you well I had an Instagram presence but
it was only like ten thousand twenty
thousand how did you already have a lot
um I just had like a daily blog of being
a medical student just be ridiculously
good looking yeah
[Laughter]
compared to what came after the violence
that's awesome but I was doing Instagram
for a while okay like from 2012 I was
consistently posting and I was really
passionate how are you gaining followers
back then was it just the recommended
feeds that people yeah at that time it
was easier to grow you would like a lot
of pictures and that would pop up for
people so like it was a teacher about it
or was it just fun I was but I was more
strategic about it for against
superficial reasons just being like a
young person being like Oh I can get
into cool events and clubs by having 10
000 followers yeah so being a broke
medical student that was a cool way of
kind of setting yourself apart so how
did BuzzFeed reach out to you they did
it they just wrote their thing they did
then people just started messaging me
like dude you're on BuzzFeed they linked
your Instagram in the article yeah the
whole article was my Instagram it was
like pictures and that was BuzzFeed at
its prime so was he wrote it trending
number one on BuzzFeed everything I
remember that story by the way you
remember I don't remember that story
yeah like from that literally that next
week Ellen DeGeneres is calling Steve
Harvey's call everyone's arguing to have
you on the show because you're like the
IT thing yeah and I didn't know what to
do so I asked for some time and then I
said you know what I'll do Ellen
Degeneres Show she was the number one at
the time so I went on to do the show I'm
about to do it
the plan was it was her she only shoots
out of LA but they were shooting a Labor
Day episode out of New York so it was
perfect I'm in New York I'm like I'm
gonna do this show a day before they
cancel on me and they say hey Hillary
Clinton is announcing her run for
presidency and the other guests are
Jimmy Kimmel and pink we're now bumping
them we're bumping you so I got bumped
off Ellen DeGeneres I'm like no problem
I'll call Steve Harvey back or all these
other shows and do that because they
wouldn't allow you to do both yeah
so I would I called and they're like Oh
no you're last week's news we don't care
about you anymore no that's it so let's
say you're done your old news now I was
kind of thinking you have to hop on this
quick you have to that's it like okay
forget about you yeah right it's like
two weeks later it was gone it was
forgotten from the major shows and then
I started doing like regular news
getting some opportunities and I would
do the hot doctor thing but under the
the invite would be because I'm a hot
doctor or that was like their title but
then I would talk about primary care or
prevention or things that I was
passionate about and just use the hot
doctor thing as the hook to get the
invite and then it kind of dried up
because the hot doctor thing fell off
and they were like well you're a young
doctor what advice do you have we have
doctors that are been practicing in ivy
league for 30 years why would we want
you on our Network so I said cool I'll
start a YouTube channel
to start a YouTube channel all from the
BuzzFeed article that was written that
prompted it yep two years after that I
started YouTube I wanted to do it
earlier but I had no skills editing or
doing any of this stuff and residencies
80 to 100 hours a week yeah how did you
find the time to balance that and was
there ever any issue with the hospital
or the doctor the place you were working
for sure having a channel talking about
it well I I started YouTube specifically
at the tail end of my residency so that
wasn't a problem but Instagram was
certainly scary to them they didn't know
what to make of that I mean again
they're in a non-profit system and
they're like what is this and all these
news agencies are calling they're
worried I'm gonna do something wrong
show patient information again they
don't know what I'm posting so it was
all new to them and it felt very
superficial because it was selfie driven
on Instagram but then once YouTube came
around and they saw what I was doing
with YouTube putting out evidence-based
info countering misinformation getting
Young Folks interested about their
health they suddenly changed their tune
like wow we love this can we get you
involved with our Hospital more they
hired me after a residency to continue
working there and now we have a great
working relationship how do you balance
the information with with making sure
everything you say is factually accurate
in what sense in the sense of like ever
giving medical advice or maybe something
that could be deemed is like you
shouldn't be saying that a line as a
doctor yeah so
there's a very important distinction to
be drawn when you're talking about
General Medical information versus
individual I'm giving you advice okay so
even if we do a responding to comments
video and someone asks a question about
their diagnosis I won't answer them I'll
say when I see a patient with this
diagnosis here's what comes to mind and
I kind of give them what's in my mind as
opposed to treating them so it's always
with the idea that we're talking in
generalities we're doing general
education not me becoming your doctor
because that is what is sure unethical
and not right and not helpful to anybody
because I can't give advice off of a
comment like there's no way
I can conceptualize everything that's
going on in their life which you need in
order to make a diagnosis including a
physical exam I found it interesting
when we were doing your podcast you made
it very clear I'm not your doctor is you
do you have to reiterate that all the
time really yeah because it means common
sense like yeah I know I know you're not
a doctor for sure I have to reiterate it
um I do it less
reiteration on my channel because I've
gotten better at answering the question
where it's clear that I'm not answering
it for you now what happens is there a
liability if you didn't say that if I
ask you hey what do you think of this
you forgot that part and you just went
into well sure that is blah blah yeah
like if a patient's like uh asks a
question not a patient if someone on
comments the thing on YouTube and says
Dr Mike like why is my ankle always hurt
after I go to the gym and I take that
comment I say your ankle hurts when you
go to the gym because you sprained your
ankle and as a result you have a weak
ligament and I make this whole diagnosis
and then they don't see care and it
turns out that they have a cancer in
their ankle they can sue me got it
because I crossed the line and I gave
them medical advice as a physician what
was the main takeaway from of Graham's
body like what was that what was the oh
yeah this would be interesting I'm just
curious because then you take away of
your body yeah because he went on your
podcast and I'm guessing you assessed
his body right
what are you implying here I'm not
implying it
his body is fantastic what okay well but
you you examined him
like what was something that you guys
went over
um his fitness journey from 2020 to 2021
um because Graham said he didn't pay
attention to his health as much as he
should have because the cost dynamics of
driving to the gym outweighed the
savings potential
I I'm guessing based off the way you
said that that I can understand your
take on that
I agree with you
I understand well the reason is because
I think that even by Graham's logic that
was a bad decision
because his logic is about getting the
most Roi right and him going to the gym
was too expensive for the time and how
much he was earning at the time per hour
but he was miscalculating that because
he wasn't factoring in the ROI from
decreasing the likelihood of future
Disease by going to and also the energy
that you get when you are in good shape
exactly yeah well I mentioned I was
feeling tired not as like lethargic a
little bit a little bit more down it's
harder to concentrate got it but overall
how did I how do I stack up like you're
not my doctor but generally
do you really think he's gonna say
something mean right now what are you
looking for Well Jack wanted like he
wants honestly he wants me to look at
your body and I haven't done that you
don't have to examine his body if you
don't imagine yeah no no there was no
medical exam done and he didn't show me
the growth that you guys were talking
about dogs yeah that growth is insane by
the way
good job
someone's gonna clip this up it's going
to sound so wrong
you gotta oh good they don't go viral
yeah what I kind of want to discuss a
little bit more is your time in
residency because to me that's like
bewildering the fact that you're wearing
80 100 hours a week meanwhile like I
assume like you were incurring
incredible amounts of debt yeah like how
was that financially how much debt did
you end up having and then the job right
out of college like how much is it yeah
so I'll give you sort of the norms and
then I'll give you what happened to me
sure so generally speaking people come
out of debt uh come out of medical
school with a debt of around 500 000 if
they took loans for both college and
Medical School uh my debt was around 300
000 because College was uh free I had a
pretty strong scholarship so I just had
to pay for like living expenses once you
come out you start working in residency
which is around 45 to 60 000 a year
depending on which specialty which
hospital
but if you calculate per hour you make
eight dollars an hour why is it so
little because technically you're also
gaining a lot of experience oversight
essentially like if you're seeing a
patient as a resident you're also being
overseen by a superior like a senior
Doctor Who's also getting paid to see
that patient so the hospital is
essentially paying both of you and they
can't afford to pay both of you a senior
doctor salary and that's why a lot of
these residency programs are
government-funded spots and that's why
we're trying to increase spots all the
time and that's something I've actually
done advocacy work for before to
increase more residency spots and then
once you come out depending on your
specialty there's a lot of variability
in how much you can earn
um you know being a primary care doctor
the earnings somewhere in the 200 to 300
000 per year range if you're and that's
after residency again that's already
like 10 years of education you just can
go into that right after graduating or
you do okay yeah after graduating
residency yes correct not Medical okay
so when did you how old were you when
you graduated residency 27 so I was
really young because the average age
going into medical school was 26.
and that's how many four years or
medical school is four years yeah so the
average age of finishing my medical
school class was 30 and I was 24. did
you graduate college very I did one of
those seven year combined programs and I
had a late birthday so it was like a lot
of combined factors there so I came out
and I was I just started my YouTube
channel and I started working for my
Hospital part-time balancing that in the
YouTube world and initially YouTube
wasn't super successful and that first
year was rough trying to figure out how
to make ends meet you'd probably hate me
because I saved zero dollars
um and I did it with the intention of
growth mindset that I wasn't saving
because the idea was that the following
year I would earn so much more and that
was true and each year over the last
five years of having the YouTube channel
our Revenue it has increased 100 each
year year to year really yeah what do
you attribute that to I think good
sort of
ethical standards when it comes to the
YouTube channel as a doctor the ads you
do are very different they carry
different weight than if you're just a
traditional influencer because you're an
expert in the field you have a medical
board behind you so there are certain
standards you have to follow not just
FTC guidelines but also the medical
board guidelines of disclosing
relationships and I would never be the
doctor that's recommending the miracle
cure-all supplements that are out there
whereas if I were to do that
my God I would be you know across 100
million Mark yearly every year
that money is out there to be made
Supple in the world and I denounced that
in supplements I do that at my expense
right can you break that what does that
involve the supplement yeah like how
does well because the way that
supplements are regulated in this
country is they're not so if I wanted to
in this room right here start a
supplement line called Dr Mike's run
faster stronger better line of
supplements I can pour the whatever the
ingredients are here stick on the label
right here and sell it on my website and
there's no rules that I'm breaking and
because of that you could make a ton of
money because I could sell those at 100
bucks a pop monthly people when there's
a subscription model already more
revenue and as a result with the
following that I have and I could say
look I'm in great shape because of this
again another claim so there's
a lot of money to be had why is there
not regulation is it because the
ingredients are not harmful to people or
is it just claims aren't verified like
what's no so the FDA which is our
regulatory Agency for pharmaceuticals
has made a stance mostly due to
lobbyists for the supplement industry to
say that they cannot regulate
supplements because they're not drugs so
they can regulate food right
um in certain ways yes but they say that
there are food supplements so they fall
out outside of their jurisdiction and
you say the main reason for that is just
lobbying correct sounds like and also
people who love their supplements also
want that lobbying there's people who
swear by their supplements and I'm not
saying all supplements are bad because
there are times where you need to take
supplements but people who love their
supplements and swear by them and make
them their identity
essentially say that we don't want the
FDA involved in this because it's going
to make the supplements more expensive
and harder to access would you recommend
the average person to be taking casual
supplements or like magnesium or like
zinc or daily like B12 it's a loaded
question because it really depends on
why you're taking them who you are what
your goals are and for how long you plan
to be taking them because
just on the outset I have two major
problems with the supplement industry
three one is the lack of Regulation
there will only be regulation on a
supplement as if there have been
side effects or negative things
associated like if there are deaths
they'll start investigating supplements
and they'll pull them off shelves but
that's a little bit too late the second
is when Consumer Reports or consumer
Labs would go and test the things on the
shelves and compare it to what's on the
nutrition list the ingredients uh like
the nutrition facts it would not match
up like 70 percent of the timely yeah so
what you're buying you're not even
really getting in most cases and then
the final thing is when they would look
at certain supplements like protein
powders there's many others they would
find like heavy metal toxicity in them
like things that are not supposed to be
in those things because they're not
carefully monitored my big big problem
is that these supplement companies prey
on what our insecurities are that we
want to be skinnier we want to be
stronger we want to have better sex
whatever it is they prey on our
insecurities they make false promises
sometimes in very shady ways where they
can get away without getting in trouble
with the FDA okay because if you say
this supplement cures cancer you will
get in trouble but if you say this
supplement has ingredient X and
ingredient X is crucially important in
fighting cancer now you're just saying
that that ingredient is good in fighting
cancer not the product
so it kind of creates some Gray Zone
that they're allowed to Market it that
way I tried one of those Focus
supplements actually did you take one
with me Jack you did did I yeah I think
you did okay and um I took it and uh we
looked afterwards and realized the
reason they market for focus is because
it has a whole bunch of casters which is
a lot of like there was a popular
supplement a weight loss supplement back
in the day that I got in a lot of
trouble because it had ephedra in it and
as a result people started having liver
toxicity serious problems people lost
their lives as a result so it's pulled
off the market and now they've
reformulated and brought it back to the
market because it was so popular I don't
even want to say it on the name of it
but it's like incredible that the
supplement industry kind of stays onto
the radar under the guise of natural
and somehow in people's minds the word
natural means safe and I have to
constantly remind my patients arsenic
cyanide natural but also poisonous and
anything in medicine is the the poison
comes from the dose and there's no such
thing as natural means all safe
supplements are not better than
medications we as doctors don't
automatically reach for medications if
there's a supplement that has been
proven to work we'd happily use that
it's they've created a really strong
Like Us Versus Them tribal is a
mentality that you have to either be in
the supplement camp or in the
traditional medicine camp and it doesn't
have to be that dichotomy we're having
an interesting conversation before we
actually started recording that was
about doctors and hypochondriacs because
I know Graham is a bit of a
hypochondriac himself
quite often I think I think it's pretty
obvious when I was like I had them all
and I went on WebMD and instead everyone
does I guess so but I went to the worst
I was like convinced
Graham is he's convinced that the worst
stuff is happening around him at all
times but I prepare for the worst at all
times that's a good strategy yeah yeah
um but yeah I was wondering going
through med school seeing all these
people in all these different situations
and like constantly being like exposed
to I don't know people like in serious
degrees Yeah does that make you worried
like when you see a mole on yourself or
when you you know what I mean your
hairline comes evacuate you're like oh
yeah so I think when you're in med
school because you lack the experience
but you have some book knowledge it is
full hypochondriac mode where you think
you have everything like you're reading
this condition and you're like about
brain cancer and you're like I had the
headache yesterday that means like
this is what I have I have brain cancer
because I had it two days in a row you
know what you didn't sleep two days in a
row because you were studying and
drinking caffeine like crazy so then
once you become a doctor you've been
practicing long enough you end up
flipping and being like brushing
everything off and thinking that it's
nothing and you actually become a really
bad patient as a result so
um it's very classic for doctors who are
parents and their child comes to them
with some kind of ache or pain them just
make your fine
this is what my dad did to me that's
interesting and you prefer that
um maybe not as a kid because I was like
I just feel constantly written off but I
think
in medicine you have to understand
that you can't just go off of symptoms
because like you saw in WebMD having a
certain mole or having a symptom like a
headache could easily be associated with
a tumor if you look at WebMD because
it's true a symptom of a tumor is
headache but not every headache leads to
a tumor so how do you make the decision
of when it is a tumor you let the
doctors who have the experience and the
knowledge to sort of guide that uh that
needle with you and what percentage of
symptoms do you think are mental versus
actual physical symptoms because I have
a housemate and every time he starts
feeling himself getting sick a little
bit what he'll do is he'll like take a
shot of whiskey like I'm gonna go for a
run okay and he'll like he is under the
belief that if he feels sick eighty
percent of the time it's mental and if
you just put yourself in a positive like
you know you become optimistic you're
like I'm going to get through this I
don't feel anything and just block it
out after a day it goes away so first of
all if you're not feeling well and
you're taking a shot and you're going
for a run that's not good medical advice
like you shouldn't okay okay
um the second is your mindset has a huge
sort of outcome as to how well you
perform in terms of healing so if you
look at those who have a positive
mindset who are optimistic just from
that we've seen faster rates of recovery
better rates of recovery with certain
conditions so mindset absolutely plays a
role at the same time we have to be very
careful and not say that these symptoms
are in your head because the symptoms
are real the pain that you're
experiencing is real the question is is
it coming from a mental Source or is it
a physical Source that's anatomical in
nature so for example if I have knee
pain but I only have knee pain when I'm
annoyed when I'm home and I'm not happy
with my living situation
that symptom is real that's a real
symptom but is the cause something wrong
with my knee or is it because my
perception of the pain when I'm unhappy
turns up the feeling of the pain the
ache that's in the knee so it's really
our perception that changes of our
symptoms but the symptoms are really
there so we want to be careful to not
write those things off interesting did
you see that Joe Rogan episode that he
released recently you probably saw the
Sam and Colby one where they were
talking about back pain and in older
people I think Joe throughout some
statistics I was wild for me to hear but
I think it was like 50 or some crazy
high number of people that experience
back pain at an older age it's actually
just all in their head again it's not in
their head the the cause could be coming
from their mind meaning that they have
pains first of all as a human that has
lived as long as we're living these days
you're gonna have aches and pains but
now the way that our mind works is we
have at our control unbeknownst to us of
volume for the pain and when we're in a
bad mental state we turn the volume on
our pain higher and when we're in a good
mood and things are going great we turn
that pain lower so if you're in a really
bad situation mentally and you're
suffering with anxiety depression you're
really upset about a situation in your
life you're experiencing trauma mentally
that pain is going to feel worse the
pain is real but your perception of it
is higher and then by experiencing the
pain and not exiting that constant
reinforcing cycle of the pain and you
telling yourself okay anatomically
there's nothing wrong
um doing everything I need to do just
doing that can snap you out of that
cycle where your negative emotions keep
feeding the pain what do you think about
David Goggins and his ability to push
through the pain and it seems like for
him it's just all mental right like he
could get I think his like famous thing
was he was running a some crazy 100 mile
thing and he like fractured his shins or
something he like kept pushing through
that I don't think that's applicable to
99.9 of the population and yeah his
thing was running like 30 miles a day
yeah there was some story where he was
literally like fractured his legs while
he was running and he just kept going
are there good takeaways from some of
the things he does probably I don't even
know the exact details of what he
recommends but we have to remember that
outliers in health are usually not good
in both directions meaning that never
exercising is not good for your body
always exercising and breaking your body
down to the point you're breaking your
shins is also not good for the body we
see this in people who over train for
Ultra marathons they have abnormalities
in their heart rhythm like their
arrhythmias start forming so like yeah
it's a balance the human body is all
based on the balance it's all
homeostasis which is like the body
trying to maintain itself in a balance
and anytime you go too far to the
extreme it's not ideal and you know
where this shows itself really cool in a
really practical way financially for you
guys
it's obvious why for someone who doesn't
have money who's of low socioeconomic
status why they don't get good health
care right they can't afford it they
don't have access to good doctors they
may not go to the ER because they're
worried about costs right so they get
worse health care but then it might
surprise you to know that people on the
higher end of the spectrum who are very
wealthy also get crap Medical Care is
that surprising
do you know why because they think they
can buy health
so they go and they say scan my body put
me in Executive Health Program make sure
there's nothing wrong with me and
therefore they get CAT scans that they
don't need now they're radiating their
bodies they're taking these supplements
that have heavy metal poisoning and then
aren't proven to do anything and as a
result they're harming their health and
they go to their doctor and their doctor
is so submissive to them because they're
paying them so much money that they say
doctor I need an antibiotic when they
have a virus and the doctor should know
that they don't need an antibiotic it's
a viral infection not a bacterial one
and a doctor because of capitalistic
forces and wanting to please their
patient gives them what they want but
it's not good for their health so
they're really wealthy and the really
poor both get bad medical care for very
different reasons wow see I'm so nervous
now because now I feel like I'm in a
Wonder so if my mentality or my
perspective on something
amplifies the actual like the the issue
at hand it's like how much of it is in
my head and if I change my mind then I
and I act as though everything's gonna
be okay and I like put that optimistic
positive attitude on and I I could be
ignoring something but it does seemingly
go away or vice versa it's like you know
but you don't have to do the dichotomy
it's not you either are positive and get
no care or are negative and get all the
care it's those are those are that's a
false choice that you're making you
could be very positive and still seek
care
it would just be hard to be able to
detect when it's you know what I mean
but it won't be you detecting it don't
leave it up to yourself like if you're
experiencing some kind of symptom that
is causing you to even wonder if you
should get it checked out
be positive but then go see the doctor
and tell the doctor everything that
you're experiencing yeah that sounds
like a pretty good answer you're doing
both yeah I have a I have a really
interesting question how come if you
know I trip over this table and I I hurt
my leg and I break my bone I I can get
treatment regardless of my ability to
pay right or most places in the US
um why doesn't that same principle
really apply to dental care like I could
have a rotting tooth that hurts so badly
and
dental care for some reason it has like
a separate insurance and and that the
work is not really performed unless you
could pay for it yeah I I don't know why
it's like that it's really bad
um and there is a rule that like I I'm
assuming you have insurance because if
you let's say get into a car accident
you don't have insurance the hospital
still has to stabilize you that's a rule
I think it's called the emtla or
something it's like a federal rule that
the hospital has to make sure you stay
alive because imagine they're waiting to
see if you have insurance before saving
your life and all of a sudden so they're
not allowed to make a decision on
whether or not to save your life based
on insurance status but
um going to see a primary doctor they
might not see if you don't have
insurance and you're not willing to able
to pay so it's different based on
emerging and non-emergent and dental
care is a lot like mental health care
why is it so difficult to get in to see
a psychologist or a psychiatrist in
comparison to seeing a cardiologist when
really if we invest more in our Mental
Health Care System we get better
outcomes in our cardiac care because as
we were just talking about your mindset
impacts your physical symptoms like not
just your knee pain but it also impacts
your blood pressure if you have a very
high blood pressure your heart has to
pump against that as a result if it's
doing that long enough it develops heart
failure and that could come as a result
of a mental health situation
so investing in our mental health would
yield tremendous returns but I'll tell
you why insurers don't do that because
they constantly swap who they're
covering so as a result usually one
insurer will cover a person for a
shorter period of time not their entire
life you'll have multiple insurance
plans throughout your life but if we
decrease that number and one insurer
covered someone throughout their whole
life then they might see the benefit of
investing in preventive Health mental
health dental health that's right
because then you'll have less problems
but because they'll see you only for
these three years they're trying to
maximize their earnings and decrease
their spending
so it's messed up that's I never thought
of that before yeah
that's mind-blowing I'm like you're
you're born I'm just asking you I'm just
asking you all the medical questions
please these are all good medical
questions what about
chiropractors because there's people who
are like oh I gotta go to the
chiropractor and then there's the
opposite who are like that's a scam
now
how does traditional medicine view
chiropractors traditional medicine has a
probably a negative skewed view of it
because there is less rigorous
randomized controlled studies which is
like kind of the gold standard that we
use to make our decisions based on like
what we believe is to be proven I think
that there are good chiropractors and
there are problematic ones who make
false promises and start practicing
outside of their scope but I also have
patients who get tremendous relief from
it it kind of falls into that Gray Zone
it depends of what's happening because a
lot of what is taught
in chiropractic medicine may not Vibe
with traditional medicine but in the end
if you're treating the body like the
muscles the fascia like true physical
conditions and you're not making false
promises on those you can help patients
a lot but I do see a lot of BS in that
space But to be fair I see a lot of BS
in the regular doctor's face as well
would doctors practice promising miracle
cures with their supplements and stuff
so it's like it just it really depends
is the bottom line when it comes to it
but I will say that all the cracking
videos on social media probably go too
far with what they're promising and when
I say too far I mean probably a lot of
the benefit that people are getting from
those are more placebo
benefit meaning that there's a person
who's authoritative person telling them
that this will help their situation and
if you have that and nothing else
happens 30 of the time it'll get better
it's like that joke from Anchorman like
30 of the time will work 100 of the time
I feel like that's still good though
right because it still does alleviate to
something if it is Placebo net positive
it could be good as long as it's not
discouraging you from seeking something
that's truly going to help your
situation one
um or B if it's not causing you harm and
there have been instances of some
chiropractors doing things and again
doctors as well that can cause harm
so some of the manipulations gone wrong
things like that so
yeah it's tough like you want to be
really responsible when you say oh
Placebo is good because it's actually
causing now positive well is it coming
at the cost of something and is there
also something negative happening but
isn't it true that you can get your like
back kind of kinked out and like does is
there a thing of just like aligning your
your backbones your spine so alignment
is probably overstated and over promised
I'm also happen to be a do like a doctor
of osteopathic medicine so I also do
some of the Hands-On manipulations and
what I want to make very clear about is
it's not a magical cure for anything the
idea of Osteopathic Medicine comes from
the idea that the body heals itself and
we are really just like accessories to
help it heal and optimize it healing and
we make use of the body's own natural
mechanisms like for example
um if you uh activate your bicep and you
let it win the body is actually sending
two signals one to the bicep to flex and
simultaneously one to the tricep to
relax
because you will not be able to flex if
your tricep gets activated in the same
moment so you get an activating signal
and an inhibitory everyone who's
watching is doing this right now exactly
yeah so you get it activating signal
here and inhibitory signal to your
tricep so if you think about that let's
say you have a spasm in your tricep you
can activate the bicep have the person
do some exercises that can help reduce
the spasm in the tricep because we're
using the body's own reflexes and
there's all sorts of things that we can
do from myofascial techniques rib
raising techniques like for example in
patients that have asthma if they're
going into a full-blown asthma attack
their work of breathing is going up
because they have to work really hard to
breathe against a closed Airway that's
what happens it becomes inflamed and
closed and tight so you get wheezing
that the whistling sound so you have to
work really hard to breathe and the
danger in asthmatic patients why they
get intubated is because they start
tiring out from breathing so hard and as
a result if they tire out too quickly
before the asthma attack resolves they
actually have a build up and trapping of
carbon dioxide and it can be deadly so
we intubate those patients and we allow
the asthma attack to recover while we
help control the removal of carbon
dioxide for them through the breathing
machine but now as an osteopathic
physician there are things that I can
work on on the ribs the muscle
surrounding the ribs the diaphragm to
help reduce some of the work of that
breathing because if they have a spasm
in their rib muscles or in their
diaphragm I can help treat it with some
very basic techniques to reduce that
labored work of breathing to potentially
buy them time where maybe they don't
need to get intubated and that's kind of
how osteopathic medicine works probably
get acids all the time but what about
cracking your back uh you cracking it
yourself yeah probably not the end of
the world like there's research that
people used to say like a popular myth
that cracking your knuckles leads to
arthritis that's been disproven we don't
see that happening the only small thing
that we've seen is if you consistently
crack your knuckles you may have lower
grip strength so it's a very minor thing
smaller small payoff for the uh
and again that's like cracking it all
the time and not doing exercises like
yeah right I do feel I do feel like
loosened up like after I crack my
fingers you know they feel a placebo or
is there actually any sort of research
about like I cracked my back it feels
better I feel more limber it's first of
all every time you're cracking your back
you're taking it through the full range
of motion so you're essentially already
opening it up by doing that and when I
say opening it up what I'm saying is by
creating movement and activating those
muscles you're bringing circulation when
you bring circulation muscles heal
better they move better you're taking
them through the full range of motion in
fact that's why they crack because
you're putting them to their end range
of motion so you're kind of stretching
that joint space you're popping that air
bubble you're creating that that noise
so yeah like yeah stretching is good and
when you stretch sometimes you hear a
popping sound so that's what people hear
but it's really the stretching the
movement that's making you feel good not
the actual pop because sometimes we do
adjustments in Osteopathic Medicine
where oftentimes you hear a pop but what
we're trying to achieve is not the pop
the pop just happens but we're trying to
take people through their full range of
motion what are some health tips or
hacks that you'd recommend just to the
average person because I was going into
this and I was going to ask like
specifically with supplements if there
are certain ones that you would take but
it sounds like that's probably not the
case but like stretching flossing like
random stuff that people probably pla
like pass uh pass on on the average day
but they probably should do well I mean
the reality of health is not only
avoiding the really bad habits that we
know are proven to shorten and hurt the
quality of your life like smoking like
excess alcohol consumption but also
doing things that we know are proven to
be good and what's proven to be good
exercise in moderate amounts you don't
have to do a lot 150 minutes a week in
modern intensity exercise not a lot if
you're thinking about how many hours are
in a week
um making sure you get seven to nine
hours of sleep that's probably the most
important one in the the people skimp
out on the most keeping social
connections alive which
for us may not be as hard because we're
still surrounded by people our age but
once folks get older those social
connections tend to dwindle and that's
where you have higher risks for
Alzheimer's early dementia because of
the lack of social connections
um and then eating a wide widely varied
plant
Rich diet you don't have to eat vegan to
be healthy you can be vegan and be
healthy but you don't have to be you
could still eat a lot of plants meaning
fruits vegetables that's important very
important wow okay because the reason
vegetables the reason why we I say to
eat those is because all those things
where they claim about supplements like
they say vitamin C is so important and
if you don't have like if you don't take
our supplement your immune system is
going to suffer this is where they lie
and I'll show you how they lie so
vitamin C is crucial to your immune
system absolutely true in fact if I cut
out all vitamin C out of your diet
eventually your gums will start bleeding
you'll develop something known as scurvy
which is something Pirates used to have
your immune system would be shot very
true
eating the diet that most people that
live the way you live you'll have plenty
of vitamin C and you'll never get to
that deficiency but what these
supplement companies promise to you is
by giving you more you'll somehow get a
bigger benefit that's not true once you
meet the minimum requirement of what you
need that's it your body doesn't need
anymore it's like delivering more
supplies to a construction zone and
hoping they'd finish the process sooner
because you delivered them more supplies
does that help no you still got to build
the actual building
so more supplies more vitamin c does not
perform better than getting just what
you need which is what you're getting I
feel like what I've noticed just in my
own life and some people that I'm close
to it's like the the common theme is
that they don't sleep enough or they
sleep in like weird hours I'm guessing
it probably is very important to go to
sleep at the same consistently yeah and
then also just not drinking enough water
yeah hydration so that's kind of one of
those points that's being touted right
now in like a sexy way where they're
like make sure you buy this app and your
phones remind you to drink water
if if you're thirsty you'll drink water
that's kind of the norm I feel like I
get so caught up where like I said all
I'll have all day is two cups of coffee
Graham does not drink very much water
like we'll literally go out there
this is a weird question is your urine
really dark uh not usually it's red
is that all right that's purple is that
normal
um but generally speaking if like you're
high again remember you're getting it
also from fruits and foods that you're
eating so like there's other ways that
you're hydrating that you may not notice
and when you're drinking a big coffee
you're also consuming a lot of water in
that coffee
um but I will say just it's over hyped
because humans have survived so long
with water being generally unavailable
to them by knowing when they get thirsty
to drink that I'm not worried that most
people are going to be really harming
their health by nothing but now I see
people like they're thirsty
and they pop open a Coca-Cola well
that's right and then they Diet Coke is
it healthy or is it not
okay healthy for what like is it a fine
way to not hydrate yourself but like is
it like unhealthy here's a good example
so I recently uh was okay I guess I'm
still on
fallen off this but weight loss Journey
lots of people are dealing with this
right okay I was a soda drinker and I
replaced coke with Coke Zero so maybe we
can kind of start there so some people
are like oh don't drink hoax here it's
like worse for you and in my head I'm
like well
first of all I don't know what's proven
and what's not but I know that probably
drinking this and substituting it for
something that I know had this much
sugar and also calories which are I'm
trying to watch is not helping so I
think this is a better option but I
don't want to compare it to that's like
the person who picks up vaping instead
of smoking they know it's better but I
don't want to compare the two because I
don't think it's that bad but maybe you
can shed some light on well I'll say it
this way your logic is correct so by
switching from a traditional Cola to a
cola that is zero calorie
you are making a healthier choice
that's objective
whether it's a hundred percent healthier
we can't really say because everyone's
body is different everyone's going to
have different choices but if in terms
of cutting down calories decreasing the
amount of carbohydrates you're taking in
it is a healthier choice in that regard
that's why I asked you in what sense is
it not healthy because if normally
you're drinking regular tap water and
all of a sudden you're going to now
drinking uh low calorie soda I wouldn't
say that's a healthier choice because
what happens is the sweetener that's
used in a lot of these colas is still
true
sugar it just your body can't absorb it
so as a result it goes to your intestine
where the bacteria can eat it and thrive
on it so as a result you have a growth
an explosion of growth of that type of
bacteria which then can actually send
signals to your brain to have you have
cravings of sugary Foods wow wow
but again it's yours so if that's if
you're switching from water and now
you're creating this like sweet tooth
mentality for yourself but in your case
you already had a sweet tooth from
drinking unhealthy soda and you're
switching to a healthier alternative I
would say that's a good change for my
patient to make but in a case of like
someone saying oh I'm just going to go
from water to this I would say ah not
ideal the ingredients aren't good the
artificial sugars generally are not
necessary and I would recommend to do
something else do you think reverse
osmosis or extremely pure water is
actually positively affecting people
just in general or negatively affecting
people rather than tap I have no idea
because I've heard tabs actually very
healthy
stuff that water generally speaking is
really healthy to drink especially in
New York City like it's very well
controlled it's tested like even if you
compare it to like a traditional spring
water that we have here in New York our
tap water has less bacteria in it the
the spring water that we get so like our
tap water is really good in New York at
least so and I don't know about the
reverse osmosis systems enough about it
what do you think about the narrative
being thrown around that like you should
eat like all meat diet
ignore vegetables it all falls into that
same extreme thing remember the body is
a balance everything is a balance
and there's no way that going extreme in
One Direction is going to be the
solution but don't you think for some
very unique specific people yes those
are outlines certain things and using
outliers to create rules is the worst
way to create rules so I'm making
General guidelines here I can't make
guidelines off outliers because if I did
then I'd be telling all you guys to run
full marathons with broken shins and and
be raw liver and eat raw liver and all
this other stuff which is not what
guidelines are supposed to do guidelines
are supposed to be middle of the road
with exceptions made for individuals wow
that's really interesting I could have
told you that Jack
I I have an interesting uh shift here so
I just want to know what was going
through your mind when you first did
Creator class because the first thing
that I thought of was and I'm sure a lot
of people was a doctor he's a doctor is
he really going to get into that ring
and punch somebody else in the face yeah
yeah that was unexpected
the oath to Do no harm to get into the
ring there um it was scary for obviously
that reason but also from a health
perspective knowing what could happen
taking shots to the head that's not
healthy especially with all the research
that's out there on CTA which is why
when I was doing it I very was explicit
with my audience that this is a risk I'm
willing to take I do not recommend this
for anyone in fact I want you to take
away from this to go move to go take a
boxing class but not to become a
professional fighter this is something
extreme that I'm doing and by labeling
extreme hopefully I'm explaining to
everybody that this is not what 99 of
the people watching me should do what
were some of the risks though the
realistic risks of getting in the ring
I'm not talking about the outliers but
like what could happen in an hour I mean
brain damage how common would you say
that that is or what what would it take
I wouldn't say it's common yeah
especially if you're not inept in the
ring but it's
it's realistic to happen
so it's not common but it's not out of
the ordinary for it to happen so like
you you want to be aware of that risk
going in make a car crash
I think a car crash should probably
happen more often I think like the rates
again we should ask an actuary this but
like I think car accidents happen way
more frequently than a serious negative
outcome from a controlled boxing
environment but why did you want to take
that risk I really love boxing I was
doing it for a while
um I wanted to take the challenge and I
thought it was a calculated risk because
I wasn't stepping in the ring with um
you know Jon Jones or some like
UFC monster or pro boxer I was stepping
in against idubbbz who I felt we were on
at least the same enough level that
the damage wouldn't be that far that if
I had to take some damage got it
you did a great fight you were wildly in
shape it made me feel like what am I
doing with my life man well what was
that diet like and what was it I had to
lose uh quite a bit of weight I was like
208 when I started and I had to cut down
to like 190. I cut down to 188 to fight
with Ian
um so actually I wasn't dieting anything
specific because when you're working out
twice a day six days a week you're
burning so many calories that even if
you eat 2500 3000 calories you're still
gonna be losing weight so I was eating
normally but still losing weight because
I was training so much wow how is your
business today broken down I'm curious
what sort of the top of the funnel yeah
so it's I mean it's all social media
driven obviously
um brand deals probably number one on
that funnel
um AdSense is up there
and then you have your alternative
income that comes in from speaking
engagements like because I have a
production company we do productions for
other people that I'm not involved in so
things like that and why did you start
the podcast
um I really like it I see that the clips
on Tick Tock yeah all the time I really
enjoy having those conversations
um I think that there's a space to have
those conversations about demystifying
health like we're doing right now with
people who are very influential
because it seems like when people get
sick they feel very disconnected and
lonely that they have this condition no
one else does and I'm hoping that my
podcast will show that everyone suffers
with this whether you're the most famous
comedian of all time or one of the most
uh successful athletes you do have
troubles with your physical health you
do have troubles with your mental health
you have problems in our shitty Health
Care system and I think bringing that to
the general public will break a lot of
stigma and hopefully decrease some of
that loneliness that we experience
that's interesting I really liked when
you talked about uh talked with Barbara
about her skin yeah she had a skin
cancer scare that her plastic surgeon of
all people found and she was really open
about her health I've actually found
that everyone coming on has been really
open of sharing their their health
histories which it's funny as a doctor
I'm so careful with HIPAA uh to be sure
that they they're very open and want to
share it or taking that uh that chance
on me but it's cool I I like the biz
this aspect of what we do and I'm very
responsible with it again because I'm a
doctor I have to be really careful with
what I recommend and the endorsements I
take on but somehow we've turned this
into a very successful uh Venture and
where are you investing I'm maximally
Diversified I have
REITs funds index funds
some crypto small amount
I love watches yeah I have some watches
I noticed what what are you wearing I've
never seen is the all black is that the
ceramic this is the ceramic uh perpetual
calendar AP when did you get that
um a few years ago
good uh good time to buy yes so it
sounds like you've bought a lot of these
watches before they just exploded in
value yeah exactly so I was very
fortunate with my timing and uh I want
to warn everyone that has seen that
happen and think that watches are a
great investment they're absolutely not
they should not be viewed as a form of
investment
um maybe some watches depending on the
brands and selections from within that
brand can hold some value but the reason
you should get a watch is because you
love the watch you love wearing it
that's like what you're getting the
enjoyment from because it's not going to
be the monetary aspect it's not a it's
not a good way to hold value I even
recently bought some gold I was really
excited about yeah physical gold or yeah
so it's funny I uh I wanted to buy one
kilogram of gold and I messaged my
friend who works on 47th Street in New
York and I said hey man I want to buy
that he goes sure come on in and I went
in and I brought a book bag for the gold
and when I walked in he hands me like
this little thing and I'm like oh what's
this tiny and I thought this is like
he's showing me kind of a print or
something like a sample of what he's
gonna sell me and he's like there you go
and I'm like wait this is it a kilo of
gold is like a business card and it's
like right now 62 64 Grand I'm like hold
on a second this is I I viewed Hollywood
gold you know those like balls and bars
and I thought that's what I was getting
that's actually like 12 or 14 kilos yeah
and way more money the actual kilo of
gold is Tiny I was really surprised
there was a house I showed in Hollywood
I have a picture somewhere I could try
to find it where
in the entry off to the left is a framed
picture built into the wall with
tamper-proof glass and there is a brick
of gold and I think I was calculating at
that time and this must have been 2010
2011 I think it was like eight hundred
thousand nine hundred thousand dollars
worth of gold in that one brick and it
was showcased in the wall of the house
yeah gold is expensive and I don't
really have a good reason as to why I
just kind of want to diverse Decor you
could buy big bars of copper oh really
not that much money okay so I wasn't
buying it for Decor well I'm just saying
if you want a cool like looking thing
here it's just yeah for Decor I just
have gold yeah
we don't do that well here but um
speaking of you know doing well and
making money
um have you ever felt a pressure to like
how do I explain it Ali abdall was a
very successful doctor and he pivoted
away from from that now have you ever
felt pressure of like why do because you
still practice have you ever felt
pressure of like why should I keep
practicing uh medicine when I make way
more money doing this online and yeah of
course you know you want to stay sharp
and stuff but what is the factor behind
you making that decision it's like full
Love of the Game so I work right now two
or three days a week in the hospital and
when I say hospital I mean Outpatient
Center
um and
I I basically do that for free and I do
that because I genuinely enjoy being
there and there was a period of time
when I finished my residency that I
initially got a license to practice
medicine in New York but then my
Hospital hired me so I had to get a new
Jersey license which took some
administrative time like two months to
get filled out and during those two
months I was still doing TV I was doing
YouTube and I was talking about medicine
but I wasn't practicing it and it felt
fraudulent I didn't feel like I was
really connected to the information
because now when I talk about a subject
I'm thinking about the patient that I
saw last week that had this condition so
when I when I hear people say oh do you
have insomnia just take magnesium that's
going to help you I guarantee it you see
tick tocks like that all the time I get
pissed at those because I think about my
patient who's truly suffering with
anxiety or insomnia and is struggling
with their life and has nothing to do
with taking a supplement because they
have a true medical problem and I get
mad at those tick tocks because I'm like
you don't see patients you don't see
what they're really going through and
you promising this miracle cure-all is
not fair to that person so I never want
to lose that aspect of truly being there
for patients and
during the times where social media is
not going well or you may be getting
some hate online or whatever it is going
to the hospital and doing the things
that people would consider boring or
working long hours tedious paperwork
have been some of the most fulfilling
moments over the last five years
surprisingly you would never guess that
but I love that and I'm also working
with my same family that I've been with
10 years who knew me before social media
popularity so they saw me work as a
doctor before I became popular so they
kind of know where I'm coming but what
about your patients now do they come in
be like oh crap that Dr Mike doctor yeah
he's treating me no no they don't no
they have real life problems they don't
watch YouTube so it's cool I would walk
in oh man sometimes yeah like sometimes
like they do their records you get
nervous or well now like so if like they
call ahead for an appointment they get
scheduled with me they might look up a
doctor because that's like kind of
reflexive these days for review sites
and then they'll see my social media so
they'll know that that way yeah but most
reflexively don't know I think we just
lost battery in one of those so I think
it's time yeah okay thank you so much
for coming out this is a great
conversation it was nice meeting you
before we end yeah we gotta look at how
the video performs one that is a one out
of ten let's go we did a one guys to the
Moon
hey all right thanks man I really
appreciate it of course this is awesome
this is my third podcast today oh really
this is today
say again